it to finance our Capital program
as such we stayed well within our
authorized limit of 96 million pounds
the cash
or the value of our cash and Investments
at the end of the financial year was 51
million pounds
leader I move the recommendations
thank you councilor Saunders and as no
one wants to
even though with the interest rates
going up I'm sure
151 is
um getting his money sacks already at
the back of the office there so um does
anyone second this uh councilor Bob
bayford do members agree
[Applause]
so moving swiftly on to the
Asset Management Ramsgate football club
item which is
um
ah I think I've got that wrong I've got
Jill bayford down I think councilor Pew
you're doing that aren't you councilor
Pugh
got the to introduce councilor Pugh
thank you chair
um
as members will see from the agenda the
agenda pack uh Ramsgate football club
has occupied the site
um for over 70 years and provides a
service to the community and
particularly encourages children to play
to play sports
the property is currently occupied under
the terms of a lease by Ramsgate
Football Club
for a term of 21 years which of course
they are currently holding over
um that has been intact since 1st of May
1992.
when I could barely walk to be honest
um but there it is
the current rent to the council the
council receives is minimal
um you know I think it's important to
know that you know we could choose to
retain this property
um or dispose of the market on a value
of lease terms but it would be difficult
and particularly raising the rent on a
Community Asset and all of the work that
the football club have put into this
into this site I don't really think that
that would be appropriate
um we've of course commissioned an
independent valuation of the premises to
assess what the current market value
would be and the value of provided in
market value of a quarter of a million
pounds
um
therefore
um considering all of this and the
parcels of land of the property like
this rarely come onto the market
um and especially on an unconditional
basis
um considering that it's located within
a residential area we want to of course
ensure that this site continued to serve
the community and is utilized for that
whether it be in our ownership or not so
therefore
um I think it's important that we
include one or both of the conditions
that there's an overage provision on any
uplifting value following a change of
use or a restriction on the use of the
land limiting it to uses as a football
club and Associated purpose only
therefore within this recommendation
both restrictions apply
um and as the tenants are considered
special purchases it would be
recommended that the property is offered
at or the site is offered at 265 000
pounds therefore
um I'd like to move to Cabinet the the
following recommendation and luckily
there's only one
um is to dispose of the property via
Freehold transfer to the owners of
Ramsgate football club at 265 000 pounds
with restriction on the use of the land
limit limiting it to uses as a football
club and Associated purposes only should
the owners wish to sell or redevelop the
land at a future date the council will
seek an overage provision of 50 on any
uplifting value following a change of
use thank you
thank you councilor Pugh before we move
on to speakers
um just to let officers members and
members of the public know we are now
live so um
just in case anyone wanted to tidy their
hair up or anything so um so on that
note um on that note I'll ask um Council
Everett to speak under 20.1
thank you later
um yeah remscope football club I think
is a good news story for thanet I
believe the top of the league I think we
should congratulate them on that and I
know that they've been doing some very
good work in the community
and you know well done for them for that
and I think anything the council can do
to encourage and support that I know the
value of football clubs working in the
community having been associated with
one of the big biggest Community schemes
in the country for a number of years
associated with the football club
Ramsgate obviously on a much lower scale
but nevertheless able to do very good
work locally and doing that and having
met the people running the club I'm
confident in them as well so I'm not
nothing negative to say about the
football club and I support this
proposal to transfer the Freehold I
think it's um I think it's the right
thing to do clearly the rent is
derisary
and I think that that will enable them
to apply for Grants and it will support
their business and we should encourage
it however and there's always however
um
I think we have to recognize that that
is not the ideal site for a football
ground
um it is problematic in terms of access
and it is limited in its potential for
development
which leads me to believe that in the
future there will be an application for
change of useful there could easily be
an application for a change of use now
that could come in five years time when
it could come in 50 years time
we don't know and I'm not saying that
that is the agenda behind this um
purchase of the site but what I do know
is that football clubs are inherently
unstable institutions and Council
soldiers and I are very well aware of
that problem at all levels and frankly
the lower you go down the pyramid the
more unstable they are so you can't rely
on the people who are running at the
moment to be there forever you can't say
whether the club will succeed on the
pitch or whether it will fail on the
pitch but both success and failure on
the pitch could lead to pressure to
dispose of that site either because they
want to go somewhere else which is
bigger and more suitable where they can
get bigger crowds in or because the
business has failed
um and in in the real world you can't
say to a football club you will continue
to play there forever
it's just not the real world and as
we've seen with all the big football
clubs that have moved so the council has
to make provision for that and whilst we
want to support Ramsgate football club I
do believe that we have a duty to the
taxpayers have thank you to protect
their interests as well
so I have some questions really about
the conditions first of all I assume
that the um obligation to continue to
use the site as a football club was some
kind of Covenant on the land and
therefore will transfer from owner to
owner because football clubs do change
hands they go bus they reform all sorts
of things happen
um and the other thing which bothers me
slightly is this 50 overage I mean I
absolutely accept it's almost impossible
to value a football ground I know this
because I've explored it at Great length
in London
because there are no other takers for
the site as a football ground almost
invariably so I don't know if 2 650 000
is the right price two six five thousand
is the right price I'm happy to accept
it probably is but on the overage I
should think the right powers of thing
will be quite unhappy if in five years
time they found that the site was being
disposed off for development and the
football club was gained 50 of the
increase in value for that development I
just think on the other end if that
happened in 50 years time everybody
would think that was perfectly
reasonable so I just asked cabinet to
consider putting some provision in the
contract to prevent this happening soon
so that we don't give away a large sum
of money potentially to somebody who
comes along and develops the site not
because I think that's the intention of
the current owners just to protect the
interests of the population of thanet in
the longer term
I hope landscape continue to thrive on
that site and I'll welcome The Proposal
in general thank you
uh yes thank you Council of it I mean
it's obviously no secret that I've been
working quite heavily on the community
side and I would argue that it is not a
good with your point about it not being
a good place for a football club this is
a hell of a lot more than a football
club and that particular location as you
know because it's adjacent or in in your
world area is um that they have
there's a lot of trust that's been put
in the Football Club
by the locals that go there with the
parents and the children and they've
they've grown to to trust the football
club and it's not just about the
football it's about the half program
there are a lot of children that go
there throughout the whole summer and
their parents and they've built up this
very close relationship with the local
community so from that point of view I
think it's an ideal place because it's
an area where there isn't a lot for for
the children to do so um that is one
part of it that is is quite humbling and
um for me when when I go there
um so the location is not all about the
access to it and whether it's a football
club to survive this is a hell of a lot
more than a football club because of the
programs that they run there and the
educational programs they run there but
I'm sure I'm a partial back to councilor
Pugh who will no doubt refer it to Mark
peace but take your point about
um the protection and that's why the 50
overage was in there but if that needs
to be stretched then obviously we'll
take the advice of the director of
property so councilor Pugh
thank you Chad and thank you councilor
over there I'm I I agree with uh much of
what you've said to him and I appreciate
your comments and your views
um what I can confirm is that the
restriction on
um only football uses is will be tied to
the title uh for the land it's not with
ramsca FC or uh whoever owns the
football club at the moment
um you know in particularly I think as
the leader has said about the 50 overage
I think both of those conditions are
designed to ensure that it continues to
be a football club and more so that it's
not just us disposing of an asset and
somebody making a quick Buck off of it
um I'm happy to defer to officers
um on your point about putting in maybe
a five-year time period or something
like that where the land couldn't be
sold for for any development or
something like that um so I'm happy to
defer to officers but you know for me as
the portfolio hold I'd happy I'd be
happy to to put in a recommendation for
maybe a five-year limit or something
like that so it can't be sold in the
next five years but again happy to defer
to marketer and to Bob
so Mark piece do you want to speak on
that point yeah hi um I thought you're
giving us an easy ride there actually
and to write until the end but you're
right um the the
restriction there's two restrictions one
is to use and one uh as to overage
provisions
so I think what you say is is quite
perceptive it would look very bad if in
a fortnight's time they put a planning
application in for a huge housing site
and it would reflect badly on us and on
probably the owners of ramscape football
club as well but that title and the
restriction on use is permanent so they
have to come for us if they want to
apply for planning permission for a
change of use at any time
so I I don't necessarily see why you
would want to time wait it it's it's
forever they've got to come to us
that's that's one point your other point
on overage
um is is good and you're right to
challenge it the the valuation was done
by steps Pairs and that's that existing
use and that's a lot lower than if if it
was valued with the benefit of planning
permission for say housing
um
however
um overage Provisions generally are
generally as low as 30 percent maximum
I've ever seen are up to about 55 60 the
reason for that is that the people who
own the land have to do a lot of work in
order to get the planning permission and
actually to do an achievable development
so they're taking all the costs in in
the development and the planning and the
legal costs and so forth so you have to
leave something in it for them or we're
not going to get anything out of it at
the end so I I think 50 is one of the
higher overage Provisions I've seen
councilor bayford
yeah thank you chairman I think the
point the council over it makes is
absolutely spot-on you know if that did
change hands you know I don't know
whether five years is the right time but
uh in any time uh it you know it's going
to be difficult and people will suggest
that oh you know their cancer has been
rolled over and whatever so it is I do
think we do need to revisit that if
that's possible
um what I do think we'd need to do
though is to make sure that we very
clearly get the message to Ramsgate
football club that is in no way a
reflection of what we think they may be
doing you know that we are totally
supportive of what they're doing and
that this is in there to protect if you
like residents of thanet and whatever
and it isn't any reflection on on what
we think may be the future of that club
okay so councilor Pugh would you like to
move an amendment or
um for this C so we'll make it Amendment
for this evening
I would share thank you so
um
therefore I'd like to table amendment
that we add in to uh the recommendation
or a secondary recommendation uh that we
put a you know a five-year there's a
five-year time period uh where the
property can't be disposed of for other
purposes or plan applications submitted
and stuff like that I'm happy to put in
that restriction however it needs to be
to be worded
foreign
I mean obviously I can't come back for
comment but not of the head is that does
that sort of
the well you can come back
I think that's sensible what I would
rather suggest is that you go off and
have a discussion outside the meeting so
you were declawed so that you can decide
that provision outside the meeting then
you can have a considered discussion
about it
yeah I just like to obviously bottom it
out today because obviously otherwise
we're going to go through the call-ins
of over you know we we don't want to
sort of delay things any longer so if we
can if count if uh Mr peace comes or Bob
Porter comes back in on it I think we
can basically do it under condition of a
time period but wording to be agreed at
a later date
yeah yeah thank you um the the
restriction on use
um obviously the lifting of that
restriction is a matter for the
council's discretion uh so it's within
the cabinet's gift uh to agree that that
discretion would not be exercised within
whatever time period you choose be it
five years or longer
okay so Council pew yeah sorry chair so
if I can come back I would then say that
the amendment I would put forward is
that the restriction on use is uh could
not be challenged for a period of five
years
um from the uh the hand in over of the
asset and then upon that it can then be
reviewed but of course in full
conjunction with uh with the council
so officers are nodding their head so I
will take that as an amendment so okay
so that is recorded as an amendment
um so you have moved that do mem do I
have a secondary counselor David
Saunders do members agree great
okay I thought that was going to be one
of the shorter items so um
so item seven housing delivery in thanet
to introduce councilor Jill bayford
thank you leader as an introduction we
I'm asking the the cabinet to endorse
the housing delivery paper attached to
this reporter Annex one and the specific
asks of the central government for
legislative and Regulatory changes to
the better balance to better balance the
delivery of new homes with the needs of
the community and for additional
national resources to increase the
delivery of new affordable homes
this report highlights the significant
mismatch between the type and
affordability of new homes being built
in the district and the needs of the
community in particular it identifies
flaws in the way in which housing
numbers are allocated across the country
and focuses on the urgent need for the
delivery of more affordable homes
the report reflects on data previously
published by the council in our housing
homelessness and rust leading strategy
in 2020.
it concludes that the household cost of
housing the need for affordable homes
and the pressures on homelessness
Services have all been significantly
impacted by economic pressures over the
past two years and the Urgent changes
are needed to ensure a better balance
between the new homes built in the
district and the needs of the community
the report sets out a series of asks of
central government designed to better
align future local plans and future
housing delivery with the needs of the
community
Cabinet member for housing it is my
intention to use this work to Lobby
central government for Urgent changes to
the National planning policy
policy framework the funding
arrangements for affordiving housing
delivery and the financial support
available for people on low incomes with
their housing costs
I move the recommendation for Council
cabinet to endorse the report on the
asks of the government
thank you councilor bayford to speak
under 20.1 first I have councilor Auburn
uh chair if I may uh could I ask that
councilor Whitehead goes before me chair
as
the shadow Cabinet member I think that
would be appropriate if I can go
afterwards that would be fine thank you
very much
that's fine yeah I've just I've got them
on a list of they came in so yeah
councilor Whitehead
thank you leader thank you councilor
bayford and thank you cancer Alvin and I
will need to ask for latitude on your
proposed timings on this item as I may
overrun in order to make a useful
contribution I ask that this latitude be
granted as option two the consideration
of additional suggestions it's a
redundant option if counselors do not
have the ability to fully explore and
explain additional suggestions
I'm more than happy to shorten my
responses to later items if this is
necessary in terms of timings but for
option two to be meaningful contribution
needs to be enabled and so I ask for
your permission to contribute in a way
that makes option two meaningful
okay well um yes we'll give some
latitude as long as
um I would ask other members speaking if
there's no repetitiveness on their
issues um I'm fine if you
um on the basis that Council Auburn has
asked councilor Whitehead to speak first
he's sort of nominating if you like the
lead on that so I'll just ask for
um if we if there is overrun then and we
can reduce the other speakers time down
accordingly thank you
firstly I would like to thank Mr Porter
and the officers involved in the
delivery of this paper it is a thorough
and extensive review of our long-term
housing delivery and the factors that
affect it
in bringing the recent call for Action
regarding housing I hope that we as a
council could do more than writing to
government yet again as we have done
that several times now and receive no
useful response both under our
Administration and under the current
Administration
the call for Action sought to address
both short-term and long-term pressures
and would have allowed us to have a full
hearing of all issues affecting housing
with the ability to call external bodies
and individuals to attend and hear where
we need support in an open and public
manner
I will always be saddened that overview
and scrutiny chose not to use that
chance or even debate that chance and
potential
however the most important thing within
politics is making sure that the
situations you are presented with work
and as such I have previously sent out
additional suggestions to cabinet which
I'll explain to others present now and
formally ask the cabinet consider
adopting these under option too
long-term plans are incredibly
significant and important
the title of this paper housing delivery
in thanet makes it very clear that the
focus here is long term which is
necessary but short-term plans are also
required alongside long-term plans and
the recommendations as they send do not
never recognize the needs or
requirements of residents currently and
borrowing the late inclusion of my
concerns and suggestions regarding
current lha rates do not offer Solutions
or suggestions to address the crisis as
it stands currently
this is not a criticism it is simply
that this report is not designed to and
does not address the short-term housing
and current housing issues that we are
facing as was stated it would do at the
last overview and scrutiny meeting it
focuses on our long-established building
strategy which stands to potentially
provide some long-term solutions that
cannot on its own address current need
the majority of this cabinet report
covers our long-term building strategy
and our housing homelessness and rough
sleeping strategy both published in 2020
this is an exceptionally long-term piece
of work both in terms of years of
preparation before this point and in
terms of the potential delivery time
frame which takes us up to 2040.
without long-term plans we struggle but
the issues we face now are immediate and
require an approach that also focuses on
that immediacy as our long-term ability
to build and a desire to reduce required
housing numbers which are the main
topics explored within this paper do not
address the housing situation that we
face now and will continue to face
I have five suggestions and adaptations
that if adopted I believe could make an
immediate impact on the stresses within
the local housing market and reduce the
displacement and homelessness that we
are seeing increase daily
if we do not ask for short-term
interventions we are quite literally
sleepwalking into disaster for the
residents who need us most
my suggestions are as follows
suggestion one alteration of
recommendation to
changing the housing requirement
calculation to use the 2018 census-based
population figures so that housing
numbers better reflect local need
I suggest that this becomes a
conditional requirement rather than an
outright one
as it's fully explained within the paper
our ability to deliver affordable
housing is currently linked inextricably
with private development via Central
legislation
I am concerned by the statement made
that using the 2018 ons data as opposed
to the 2014 data will Aid our delivery
of affordable housing and better reflect
local need as I genuinely see can't
can't see how it will do it will simply
Aid our ability to meet targets as we
will be required to deliver fewer
affordable homes
our aim should not be to reduce
requirements in order to achieve targets
it should be to deliver more affordable
housing rather than reducing the amount
we are required to deliver
concerns in relation to this are
registered within the paper
the planning practice guidance states
that the 2014 based household
predictions are used within the standard
method to ensure that historic under
delivery and declining affordability are
reflected
we have historically under delivered on
housing through no fault of our own and
the population changes in our area are
currently unclear we know that fanet is
becoming increasingly popular especially
with those with families and revising
our need for affordable housing
downwards would to my mind be unwise in
relation to the increase in homelessness
and private sector evictions that we are
seeing
housing affordability does not currently
address these changes in demographics
as the cost of living crisis continues
the percentage of families living in
this area requiring affordable housing
will increase not decrease unless we are
happy to accept displacement of local
residents and those on Lower incomes
I for one I'm not
as such I suggest an amendment that at
the urges the adoption of the 2019 ons
figures only on condition that social
and affordable housing delivery is
divorced from private sector delivering
as requested in the second
recommendation
one without the other simply reduces the
number of affordable units we are
required to build and that helps only
our targets not our residents
recommendation 3 within the cabinet
report also removes concerns relating to
potential sanctions linked to the
housing delivery test which would
otherwise be a concern with this
alteration
without the concerns of sanctions
however I see no reason to reduce the
number of affordable homes we are
required to provide as the number we
need is ever increasing and will
increase further due to the cost of
living crisis
instead we should Simply Be applying
pressure to central government to
divorce affordable housing delivery from
private development and therefore
deliver what we actually need as an area
two alteration to recommendation 7.
properly funded National program of
affordable housing delivering that is
reflective of the scale of needs locally
and nationally with increased Grant
rates to enable providers to compete for
available land
I suggest an alteration from affordable
to social
housing is the most stable most
affordable and most constant long-term
housing delivery option
Council developments are also the best
informed are planned with local need at
the Forefront of considerations and are
not subject to external considerations
our residents need the security and
reliability that social housing provides
and councils need direct investment to
both extend and enhance our housing
stock councilor Whitehead could I just
um sorry we're already up to six seven
minutes um could I just ask you to just
because obviously you sent this paper to
Cabinet earlier
um could you um go through the the title
of the points and then just the brief
summary of it because otherwise we could
be
we've obviously got to take into account
all of this information you sent it
through today quite happy to share that
obviously if you're happy to share it
with other members uh for them for it to
be brought it's got to be brought back
to consideration but um so if you would
like to just read out the your
highlighted points and then the just the
the first sort of sentence of summary to
it yeah if that's okay so I have roughly
a minute left to go because the last
three are quite short thank you
um three increase in council tax on
second homes
we can also commit now as a council to
introducing the discretionary 100
premium on second times within our
district as proposed within the leveling
up and regeneration bill this is
something that we can do independently
rather than as a direct ask from
government as it should be in place by
April 1st 2024. but we can also write to
them to express our support for the
suggested changes and commit to this as
a council ahead of time to not only
indicate to Residents that we are taking
housing availability seriously but to
also give a clear period before
introduction to raise awareness of the
changes
for reversal of current stamp Duty cuts
the recent plans to cut stamp Duty will
further exacerbate both the shortages
and rental properties and the rent
hyperinflation that we are seeing within
planet
using property as an economic stimulus
does not work long term and especially
does not work for areas such as Planet
cuts the stamp Duty will produce
increased rent and lower property
availability across than it
five introduction of new planning class
for short-term rentals and Airbnb
as we're already directly asking for
legislative and Regulatory changes it
makes sense to also ask for ones that
can make an immediate impact
one such change would be an adoption of
a new usage class within planning to
allow for monitoring of and if necessary
planning permission requirements for new
whole unit short-term rentals and
airbnbs
we can request as I requested previously
that a C5 use class is introduced into
primary planning legislation to enable
us and other councils to have the
ability to effectively Monitor and
manage the levels of temporary
accommodation such as Airbnb so that our
district is able to provide long-term
homes for those who need them thank you
thank you councilor whiteheader
councilor Bayfield Jill Baker would you
like to respond
um yeah I'd like to thank councilor
Whitehead for all the work she's put in
um our paper is complete and
arrangements are being made for a
meeting with the Secretary of State the
very valid points that you have made
will be discussed when this meeting
takes place thank you very much
thank you very much councilor bayford
just like to add that um the both of our
MPS we are going with a two-pronged
attack but also with Kent County Council
so the papers have gone to them an
appointment with the secretary of state
has been requested we can't request to
see the Minister of Housing because it's
not yet been appointed but we decided to
go to the top
and the request has gone in and we're
very hopeful that we will get in front
of him and obviously the whole purpose
of this paper which actually the whole
the start of it was goes back to March
and then it's been added to since in in
June and July it was hope to go to
the government before the recess but
then obviously there was a lot of change
of
of Secretary of States due to various
removals and so we're unfortunately we
weren't able to approach them before but
um as as councilor bayford has said this
is really a foundation paper that is was
used and prepared to get us in front of
the minister and then all other points
can be added at the time
um because obviously it's a very it's a
moving feast all the time and with the
you know energy crisis and with the
housing you know uh We've now hear that
mortgage rates are going to go up
there's all sorts of factors that just
keep pouring on top of this so um this
will be the basis of the discussion
paper and then all the other bits can
can be added in and I'm sure that uh
because some of the suggestions cross
over into various different departments
treasury planning you know there's all
sorts of departments that would come to
involve with that so I mean if we come
away with getting one result out of it
one point then then we've at least you
know done our best and got in front of
them which is a lot more than a lot of
other District councils have done so
um my thanks do go to
um Bob Porter and his team because there
was a lot of work that went into this
and it goes right back but as you can
see than it has always struggled to
to do what it needed to do and I think
this challenges the whole mechanism and
the whole lack of joined up thinking
with everything so um if we can at least
manage to draw enough attention to that
so thank you for your points and they
will be used as a discussion points when
we manage to get to Westminster thank
you
sorry just to clarify if we are taking
the points forward does that mean we're
accepting option two because those would
be that would be taking forward
alternative suggestions and amendments
no well I've got to come back to because
it's obviously
um councilor bayford's paper but but no
the paper is is is there and what we're
saying is is that these points will be
raised when we get in front of the
Secretary of State on your behalf as
requested through this
yes I'd just like to endorse that um a
lot of work's gone into this paper
it's and
it's been supported by meetings at the
cabinet Advisory Group and our regular
meetings with Bob Porter
so I feel that enough work has been done
to put this together
um and as as the leader has suggested
when it comes to this meeting all these
points will be considered
uh Council Auburn would you like to
follow
thank you chair yeah um different to
councilor Whitehead
um I'm not as eloquent as Council white
as you know
um but I was passionate and um
for me
um
as you know I wrote to your good self
and counselor bayford
some a couple of months ago now I think
and included the MPN
into
the state of our housing and
the issues and problems that our that
our residents face
unfortunately
um
Craig McKinley didn't even acknowledge
it
and he's probably too busy with a plane
or trying to get some 250 million pound
boat for rich people um but anyway
um that's by the buyer
um
I think what we need to take with any
report what's missing is not in it is
the human factor and it is our residence
that are facing real hard and tough
times
um the the reason I wrote you I was
angry I was so angry about the situation
that this particular family was was was
faced with
with uh
born a bread here
husband wife
Twins and a and a very newborn baby
through no fault of their their own
wrenching up
a
property
um which was quite squally to to be
honest and the owner decided to sell
sorry councilman you're you're delving
into into personal casework so just no
no I'm not going to say okay
no no I won't get a Chinese Buddy's name
or do anything like that all right okay
let me put it down the point of the
point of the matter is
is is that we have a situation here
where it is across other places across
Kent where families through no fault of
their own are being uh that they're
losing their housing the rents are so
high they cannot afford to go anywhere
else
and they end up on emergency housing and
our officers did everything that they
could
but we haven't got emergency housing
here we can't we've got nowhere to put
up put them up initially they were told
everyone might have to go to
Wolverhampton and what what the effects
of it is they subsequently event and
ended up in Chatham but what what the
consequences of that are is that
the person that the husband was working
here is now probably going to lose his
lose his job
the the children about to lose their
school they've had to reset up home
somewhere through no fault of their own
this is the things that when you talk to
the Secretary of State that he he or she
have to know about and affordable and we
do need and pick up Council of the white
Edge point we do need Council housing
not just affordable housing because even
most of the people who live they can't
even afford the affordable housing okay
um I am I'm sorry I'm passionate about
it and I'm angry about it and I'm angry
that this is a caseload that we're
constantly getting and we as a council
and I'm very pleased that you're what
you're doing leader but we need to
ensure that they get the full brunt of
what is happening on the ground thank
you leader
well as you you know
enough I think to know that every time I
do anything they get the full brunt of
everything so um
I like you and like everybody we all
share the pain of this because it's not
just happening in your world it's
happening in every every single World
there is no different across the whole
of thanet there's no different across
the whole of Kent and it's actually
across the whole country and and I
actually agree that it is in a terrible
State and we do have I mean we have
endless discussions at Kent level
because Kent have the added problem of
unaccompanied used to house and we have
and you know an immigration problem we
have horrendous problems here and if I
had a silver bullet I would love to be
able to go to the government tomorrow
and borrow 100 million pounds and build
two and a half thousand homes in this
District but unfortunately then we come
up against another problem is that we
don't have enough land in this district
and then when we do try and build
everybody doesn't want buildings so you
know you there is an endless Circle so
you know I don't know what the answer is
we either got to go up we've got to go
out or we've got it but that but the
money is probably is is doable but it's
just having the land and I agree with
you this Council and every other Council
needs to rebuild its social housing
stock and that so by affordable housing
what is meant by that is whether we
build it or whether whether we build it
or whether developers build it but we're
not in control of developers but we can
actually focus on our own stock and that
is certainly something that we're doing
and um I think
Bob Porter will will tell you that I go
to him probably once a week with an idea
about a site but these things take time
they take money and there's a lot of
complications regarding the planning but
I really do wish that we had a silver
bullet but um you know we are doing
everything we can as an Administration
and I will say at least you know
we can because it is a conservative
government we can get in front of them
and Roger Gale does actually manage to
achieve that so I'm not going to comment
on Craig McKinley but uh
um I I don't no but um you know you you
need to take that out with him
personally but you know both MPS have
been asked to support this Roger Goff is
is absolutely on this as well we had
um a meeting he called it last Friday at
half past six Friday night to talk about
this self-same subject so we all
everybody's on on the case it's just the
case of what do we do so we all share
that your passion so you are not alone
in in that in that frustration as well
okay you can always join me on five
o'clock at eight eight o'clock on a
Friday night with Roger Goff because
it's such a pleasure thanks anyway
thank you yes I'd just like to again
reinforce the fact that we feel that
passion too I on a daily basis I get
letters of the kind that you've
described at weekends I have phone calls
I have emails which I deal with there
and then there is no magic solution I
wish there was but this is why we're
taking the action we are we are taking
and certainly all these points will be
made very very
strongly when we get the opportunity to
talk to Secretary of State thank you
thank you so I have councilor Garner
thank you leader
I'd like to start as well by thanking
councilor Jill bayford and housing
officers for producing this report
I can see a lot of work has gone into it
and a lot of thought has gone into the
proposed ass of the government many of
which I'm sure we would all like to see
happen among them I'd certainly like to
see a properly funded National program
of affordable housing delivery we can
maybe call it a council house delivery
program which would see the type of
housing really needed by people in
thanet being built
there are however asks which haven't
been included which should be considered
at the most recent overview and scrutiny
meeting whereas a non-member of the
committee I was allowed to speak I
highlighted a few areas of immediate
concern which need to be tackled some of
which could be considered without
government intervention
councilor Whitehead has drawn attention
to these relating to airbnb's empty
properties and second homes and so I'll
just add that I agree with her
suggestions on all of these
has for our best to get the government
to act I don't believe that yet another
letter do whoever is this month's
housing Minister and I must admit I
thought it was currently Marcus Jones
although I'll I'll be led by
is it now okay
okay well I'll update my script
yeah well I think that yeah I mean I
think that unfortunately gives some
indication as to how seriously they take
this problem we already know that this
government is not interested in
intervening to fix these problems in a
way that delivers a housing that's most
needed according to reports I read
earlier today they look to be developing
what could only be described as a
trickle-down housing strategy which
would see them deregulate the planning
system and leave affordable housing
delivery to the market and we know who
benefits most from any trickle-down
solution
to anything and it isn't the people who
are most in need of help or in this case
affordable housing
all solutions need to be considered and
I believe along with a number of others
here it was wrong
for the most recent overview and
scrutiny committee to reviews to even
debate a call of to action on housing
which could have enabled us to conduct a
full hearing into these issues we need
to hear from our MPS Craig McKinley and
Sir Roger Gayle about what they're going
to do to persuade their government to
take the action needed to help their
constituents and a full public hearing
would have been an idea ideal place for
them to do this
thank you
councilor bayford thank you councilor
Garner um obviously a lot of the the
solutions to this have been
um already suggested in our letter but
um
and we have already engaged our MPS as
the leader has said
um it's agreed that the control of
airbnbs would be beneficial to a local
housing market although not specifically
the subject of this paper we are engaged
with work to better understand the local
holiday let market and would support any
proposals to introduce a mandatory
National registration scheme
looks
uh Council Austin
thank you leader
um
thank you very much to councilor bayford
and uh Bob and his team for this paper
it's excellent and and thoroughly
comprehensive and also contains a lot of
useful information for those of us who
are not experts in housing I think it's
extremely positive about the the
information that you've shared this
evening about the possibility of a
meeting with the Secretary of State
however I do share counselor Whitehead's
concerns about this being a long-term
strategy rather than a short-term one
and I'd like to compliment councilor
Whitehead on the huge amount of work
that she has also put in to the call to
action and to the today's paper
I think there are things that obviously
are bubbling under like discussion about
airbnbs that we need to take forward
very quickly I don't see any reason why
we can't immediately Implement a 200
council tax rate for second homes
Maidstone Council have done it other
councils in Kent have done it I don't
understand why we can't do that
um I do think we need to be looking at
immediate measures and I share counselor
Whitehead and counselor Garner's
disappointment that we were not able to
discuss this at overview in scrutiny as
a mere member of the committee who
didn't actually get a word in at that
meeting at all because of the way that
it was handled I think that was very
disappointing and I think most
particularly it sent a very bad message
to members of the public who were
attending some of whom were directly
affected by the housing crisis we really
need to be open about this and we need
to be discussing these issues as openly
as we can and to be coming up with a
variety of solutions thank you
cancel the base I'm going to hand to you
but um I think also um section 151 would
like to come in with advice on the 200
council tax
um
so I'll hand you back to councilor
bayford and then we'll pass
just to say again that the moves that we
are making address the issues that that
you have given us to be perfectly honest
I cannot see how any any solutions can
be very very short-term these things
need to be
put into place with careful planning
and strategies but I think there is one
I think particular particular that
you're able to help us with
thank you councilor yes um so there are
some powers in place already to charge
for long-term empty properties not
second homes and in fact that's the
policy that we already have in place
here in thanet so properties are
long-term empty for two years or more
you can charge a premium and that
premium that increases depending on the
length of time the property is empty
what's going through Parliament at the
moment on government is they're leveling
up and regeneration bill when that is
passed and against Royal ascent that
will allow us the ability to charge a
premium on second homes and also will
reduce the period of time from two years
to one year for the doubling up on
long-term empties we've also got to
consult on that for a year before it
comes into power so although it's
expected it will gain Royal Ascent in
this financial year we'll be looking to
implement that policy from April 2024.
councilor Everett
yeah thank you I don't want to repeat
things that have been said but I
do commend councilor Whitehead for the
enormous amount of work that she's put
into this and I think that certainly on
our side and I think on your side we all
respect that she's got a level of
expertise deriving from the amount of
effort she's put on it and of course I
respect the work done by officers and
Cabinet in in putting this Rapport
together
I think if we're going to talk about
cross-party working then there has to be
an opportunity for opposition members to
speak and debate items cabinet isn't the
place for that
um scrutiny is the place for that
um quite frankly the conduct of the last
scrutiny meeting was disgraceful and I
don't hold you responsible for that
because you're not the chair of scrutiny
although you are responsible for the
chair being the chair
it kind of it cannot ever be right that
the chair speaks on the subject for 20
minutes but no member of the committee
is allowed to speak on it and you know
full well that your seven members all
put their hands up to not allow any
debate I think that was a disgrace and I
think those members should be
embarrassed
we want to work cross party with you we
will do that when we're allowed to have
a proper debate with you in a forum
where we can have an exchange of ideas
not cabinet because that is really what
goes on the cabinet as we all know we
need an open discussion most of all
because we need to speak up for our
residents we need to voice the anguish
that they are experiencing and you can't
do that in a report we could have done
it in the form that was proposed by
councilor Whitehead we don't have to go
into details and invade people's privacy
but I deal on a regular basis as a new
internal War counselor with people who
are in extremely difficult housing
situations and why you say that it is
spread across that and I accept of
course that it affects all Awards some
Wards are more effective than others and
I'm particularly conscious of it and I
am aimlessly frustrated by my inability
to help those residents because they
look to us for help and we're not able
to give it that isn't your fault as a
Cabinet I'm not blaming you for it
there's a long-term strategic problem
here which we'll try to address in the
paper but it is so important that their
voices are heard now and that they feel
the political system listens to them and
reacts to them and if we shut down
debate we don't allow that I would like
to ask I'd like to ask you to ask the
chair of scrutiny to table this paper as
an item at the next scrutiny meeting
don't believe you can tell him but you
can request it and then we can have a
debate where everyone can have their say
thank you
councilor Byford this is yours I mean I
have to take that away and consider it I
don't actually believe that scrutiny is
the right place for it I think that
um we can have sensible discussions
across party
um without having to bring a call for
Action because
my call for Action is I picked the phone
up and I and I speak to someone and I
say this is what I want to do and that's
exactly what I did when I asked Roger
Gale to write to the Secretary of State
here is the letter I asked him to write
the letter he wrote the letter the same
day and he has asked the Secretary of
State to get in front that is a call for
Action that is what I do I don't bring I
don't feel that we need to have emotions
and that is exactly why I can't bring it
to scrutiny scrutiny you just slow it
down I want to get in front of the
Secretary of State I will pass on this
message as leader of this Council you
elected me as leader of this Council I
represent you councilor Whitehead as
quite rightly asked me to make these
points and I will quite happily
councilor Alban has asked me to make the
points his email is what probably
kicked it more into action this this
paper was written back in March April
May time and it was a it was a it was a
combination of my frustrations where I
couldn't get the government to even
begin to think about joined up thinking
but I knew that if we could get in front
of them that is when you get action when
you get in front of them you can write
letters like you rightly say I write
letters on a daily basis to the
government and they don't it doesn't get
the attention that it needs but as you
know with my call for action on this
government on this to this government to
sort this Council out I know that that
was something that was heavily debated
and well the way that I did it etc etc
but it did get some action and a year
later we've got an end we've got an end
result to doing that so you have to get
in front of these people and when you
get that opportunity you have to take it
and I can assure you as leader of this
Council I will take all these points and
I will put them to the Secretary of
State if he grants me an audience and
then we'll see where we go from there
but most of of these points are central
government issues I wish I could change
everything but unless I get elected to
number 10 and I'm not really sure that I
can actually bring them into Force but I
will do everything I can to be the voice
of thanet so I will speak to
um that I think the monitoring officer
really we will have a conversation about
how best we can actually share this I
don't actually think overviewing
scrutiny is the right way to do it
but I'm open to discussion on that but
quite happy to meet with any group at
any time to discuss what they might want
me to put in front of the Secretary of
State and I will inform everybody and
when we get that appointment when we get
that meeting but we can't all March up
there but well you can but I'm not sure
we'll get in
councilor bayford do you want
um just to say that I also thought that
the call for reaction was inappropriate
in that it did not reflect the huge
amount of work that a housing team are
doing
um
as for
I mean I feel that the work has that's
gone into this this paper it should
remain as it is
but I'm happy if you feel leader that
you would like to
Delight somewhat so that we can take in
other views I mean you've already said
that you're happy to to put forward all
the views that members here have given
tonight
foreign
because the whole point of it action the
word action is get the action so I've
activated it now we've we've we've asked
for a meeting it would be childish for
me to take the Secretary of State I will
actually hang on a minute because we
want to we want to make amendments I'm
quite able to actually add
um commentary to to the paper this is a
foundation document this is what the
whole point of it was this was uh if you
like it's an aide Memoir because I
needed to go back I'd look back at
documents local plans back to 2005.
for the history of how we failed over
the years it's not just the failure of
this government it's the failure over
the years have been that not been able
to actually
keep the housing stocks is a combination
of different governments over different
periods but what we can do is no good
keep looking backwards and saying what's
gone wrong in the past
the Silver Bullet is to build social
housing in this Council and if I can
find a way to do that which is money and
land are they're the two things that we
don't have but if we can find a way and
even to start chewing around the edges
of it but it is a national problem until
the government change the whole way that
they they work or don't work together
then we are in trouble but our job is to
just keep banging the drum until
eventually they listen or there's a
change of government so if there's a
change of government in the next
election then it will be your turn to go
and Bang the Drum with your government
so councilor Whitehead um I think you've
already spoken but I will indulge you
with um thank you it's a very brief one
um and it's simply that this is the
second time it's been said that I was
disrespecting officers in bringing the
call for action
and at no point in none of the paperwork
and in none of my presentations did I
ever criticize a single officer or our
housing program or a cabinet
it's just not correct and it's not
inappropriate because everything I've
said about bringing external forces to
bear on this in order to solve it you
said in a press article so if I am
inappropriate that was also
inappropriate and I don't think that's
correct or fair to me thank you
I didn't say respect I said reflect I
said that the call for Action did not
reflect the hard work that the opposite
did apparently
I felt it was sorry okay
councilor Bailey
uh thank you later I don't think I need
to elaborate anymore I think
everything's been said I just hope you
can take some of this passion that
you've seen tonight when you meet the
minister thank you
um well we're not lacking in passion in
this room and I'm certainly never
lacking impassion with any subject to
this this is
a very emotive subject and we all are
passionate about it and uh if we can
just get a little bit done about it then
I think we've done well
um I think that is all the speakers so
um
councilor bayford you have asked members
to on recommendation one
seconder
councilor Pugh
do members agree
item 8 Margate Town deal project Theater
Royal Margate councilor pewter introduce
to be bringing this report's cabinet in
order to be able to commence delivery of
one of the Margate Town deal projects
delivery of Theater Royal
this project has been approved by
central government and the funding is
due to arrive by the end of the month as
part of the market Town deal the theater
Royal Margate has an allocation of 2
million pounds to deliver much needed
Works to the theater to the theater this
funding will help unlock other public
and private match funding in order to
develop a hub of Performing Arts in
Margate this is an exciting time for
margate's Creative Industries and the
theater provides a significant
opportunity to build on the performance
arts for Margaret in The Wider area
I would like to therefore recommend that
one we give delegated authority to the
director of regeneration in consultation
with the interim director of property to
market the proposal for the theater
Royal and 19 holy Square in order to
identify an operator or commercial
partner
therefore giving delegated authority to
the interim director and interim head of
legal and monitoring and and monitoring
officer in consultation with the
portfolio holder to negotiate the lease
heads of terms and all other ancillary
documents
and in addition the finalized lease to
at least heads of terms and relevant
ancillary documents to be brought back
to cabinet for file approval number two
unfortunately the expression of interest
to the Arts Council England cultural
Development Fund has not been successful
therefore I removed this recommendation
we will however be talking to the Arts
Council and considering other mechanisms
for public and private sector investment
recommendation number three approve the
submission of an application for a
development phase Grant to the National
Lottery Heritage fund
and in turn authorize the director of
regeneration to agree the final
submission documents based on approval
from the section 151 officer and finally
recommendation number four is to approve
the commissioning of the Urgent works of
Theater Royal as set out in surveys
completed in 2021 funded from historic
England thank you
you can't slip you um to speak under
20.1 councilor Whitehead
thank you leader and thank you councilor
Pugh
um to be honest most of my question
revolved around the
relation of the funding bids for the
sort of Hub and spoke thing that was
being proposed for the um cliftonville
cultural space and so all I really have
to say um is that I'm fully in support
of the Urgent Works required to base the
theater and to 19 Hawley Square
especially as planting rest number 19
shows the urgency of our progress
especially in relation to sculpture
words structural works
um and
most of my query really has been
answered by that so I can be mercifully
brief thank you
councilor Pugh do you want to
[Music]
yeah thank you chair uh thank you
councilor Whitehead that's all
uh also to speak under 20.1 Council
Yates
thank you leader
um and I welcome this report as it will
mean that the theater Royal repairs can
be commissioned as soon as possible and
I think Avon will welcomes that and it's
good to hear the money
will be with us by the end of the month
so we can start that process
um just two questions
um the first is
um
around
um the actual
seating within the theater all now I've
raised this previously I had had no
answer but I believe the seating as is
the theater was being given away
um and I'd like to know whether that's
true and if if it has been given away
what process is font is being followed
to ensure these public assets are sold
or transferred in an open and
transparent manner so that's the first
question second second questions
um
when we're discussing the lease with
operators we'll can we include some
obligations on The Operators or owners
uh to in include local community groups
local organizations as part of their
offering because I know theater of Royal
has supported
um local groups in the past thank you
um
the seating but I don't know if Council
appear might have to pass it over to the
property director for that but Council
Depew are you aware of any seating yeah
thank you chair um I'll hand that over
to our director of property um on the
second point that you raise councilor
Yates
um I'm happy to look into that we can
explore that and putting that in as a
condition in the heads of terms I think
at this stage I think it's important
that we kind of get started with all of
this but that's certainly something that
we can we can look into but I'll defer
to our director of property mark on on
the uh the seating
um we've had inquiries about it but we
haven't sold any seating in the theater
role
and it was there last week when I
inspected it's good to hear those rumors
dispelled
chair if I could just come back just
quickly just to um I'd just like to
defer to our director of regeneration
particularly on the community aspect so
that she can come back to on your uh
your point cancel Yates
thanks part of the theater Royal project
is about creating a hub for Performing
Arts and it is about engaging with
communities to be able to take advantage
of the spaces we've got but also some of
the amazing organizations that we've got
in in the district and working within
Performing Arts so it is something that
will be part of the brief that goes out
to identify either an operator or a
commercial partner because we know that
the theater Royal will be very dependent
on the success of working with local
communities
foreign
actually slipping um from the tops top
slot of the land of conspiracy so um
on that point uh councilor Pew you've um
moved the recommendations do I have a
secondary councilor David Saunders do
members agree
item nine Asset Management your leisure
leases
councilor David Saunders
well leader I'm totally unprepared
because
um I've got the my paperwork that this
is down to my colleague on my right
sorry it is me
um if you're happy for me to take it on
David that's okay I'm happy you'll take
it on while I'm interested in is the
money when it comes in and we've um we
found someone to cover the leases thank
you well right okay so follow the money
so um on that case my paperwork is wrong
so my apologies I should actually know
this but um I know you love fighting
between you on this subject so um
counselor Pugh to introduce
I have yeah thank you thank you
councilor Saunders it's a shame because
you could have taken this one off if I'd
have known could have taken this one off
my back for tonight but uh but no
worries
um as members will see from the uh the
cabinet agenda item report
um the lease is in the original lease uh
for your leisure in the buildings that
they lease off of us dates back to 1999
and for many of you as a reference to
myself that was around the time that I
was in Primary School
um and probably uh taking swimming
lessons at Heartstone Leisure Center
um
[Music]
uh this includes many of the buildings
um
uh from uh from back from 1999 he
includes more buildings than currently
uh your leisure uh run and operate
um and some of these have been gradually
surrendered back to TDC and the existing
lease covers North down house uh the
Winter Gardens Hearthstone Leisure
Center and Ramsgate Leisure Center and
of course members will know that the
Winter Gardens was taken back
um under the custodianship of the
Council on the 12th of August of this
year
um
within the district Advantage your
leisure manages a range of facilities
and services under the existing lease
and annual funding arrangements with the
council
there will be separate leases put
forward within this uh this motion's
recommendation for both Rams getting
enhance down Leisure centers and the
heads of terms will include break
Clauses so that we can continue to
monitor the situation and I think it
provides a bit more of stability
particularly not just for your leisure
but also for the council and for
residents as well
um
therefore I would like to oh sorry the
the recommendation heads of terms agreed
being negotiated with your leisure is
influenced by four key factors uh these
being the financial implications of the
coronavirus pandemic and future
viability the lack of local Authority
funding to provide the required
operational subsidy the ongoing and
substantial maintenance repair and
refurbishment costs and the opportunity
for TDC to utilize funding from the
Margate Town deal fund therefore I would
like to put forward the following
recommendations and bear with me because
there are there are five but I will get
through them all one is to agree to
surrender of the current lease in its
totality and re-grant to new independent
leases for hearts down Leisure Center
and Ramsgate Leisure Center two to give
delegated authority to the interim
director of property to enter into a
relevant agreement or agreement for new
leases with your leisure on terms to be
agreed free to give delegated authority
to the acting Director of Finance and
operations to negotiate the sharing
agreement with your leisure for The
Wider provision of services provided
through your leisure at all to give
delegated authority to the acting
Director of Finance and operations to
negotiate the service concession
agreement with your leisure for The
Wider position of foreshore related
activities and finally recommendation
number five to give delegated authority
to the director of Law and democracy to
sign all documents necessary to give
effect to the surrender and subsequent
leases thank you
foreign
[Music]
officer would like to come in just a
collection on five the reason director
of law is a head of legal so can we make
the amendment please
yes
so thank you councilor Pugh and to speak
on the 21.
councilor Whitehead sorry list there
councilor waiting thank you leader
um it's probably just me but the
arrangement of the options within this
item I found slightly confusing just in
terms of numbering as 3.2 is a
recommendation also includes 3.23 to 3.5
all of which could be potentially
separate items and so it's this that I
wish to ask for further Clarity on
I am in support of the two new leases as
I feel they are likely necessary in the
current scenario however I also feel
that we should as a council have a
greater degree of control if only in
availability of information in terms of
the surrendered leases and the potential
future management of services
I have no issue with delegating although
others here are perfectly free to
disagree with that statement but we are
here speaking of the negotiation and
delegation of service provision that
could potentially be managed in-house
and produce a significant societal value
and income generation for the council
as an example of this councilor Yates
was a strong proponent of an in-house
beach hut Service as am I to both extend
our provision and allow for direct
income generation investing to earn in
order to create revenue is important but
without knowing the specifics of
Delegation or the future of those leases
that are being surrendered or
renegotiated we are potentially losing
in touch into services that could
provide significant opportunity if
subject to counselor input
as such I would like to ask for
clarification on the leases and
functions that are due to be subject to
delegation and ask evident to consider
addressing these through the cabinet
system rather than via delegation so
that counselors can offer ideas and
strategies to inform potential plans
thank you
councilor Pugh
do we refer it to 151 yeah thank you
chair I'll refer it to our 151 officer
for clarity
thank you councilor
um
I think it's would be of um
uh benefit actually if this is discussed
outside of this meeting and we give a
full response back at that point of time
if that's acceptable rather than
um rather than dishonoring at this point
in time what elements of the delegations
are considered appropriate has been
considered previously but I think a
further discussion would be merited if
you're an agreement chair
absolutely this is a highly complex and
intricate mechanism and highly sensitive
because this is about an outside body so
I think obviously take the advice of the
151 more than happy to call a
um
well cabinet and Shadow if that's okay
and then the cabinet can then refer the
shadow can refer it back to group or if
you want an extended meeting from that
um
a combined cabinet Shadow because it is
a very complex subject and um there
again there's there's no Silver Bullet
to this one either so um I think it
would be
appropriate to do that so if counselor
Pugh that can be arranged then I'm sure
that we can have an opening discussion
if uh group leaders want if they come as
well so that covers the uh the other
groups as well to be invited in that's
okay Council pew yeah thank you chair um
yeah I think that's absolutely fine I
think that's certainly something that we
can uh get set up and arranged um and I
appreciate uh the strength and feeling
um particularly around
um you know varying options and
opportunities there may be uh thought
particularly to do with our foreshores
and our beach huts and everything you
know I think it goes without saying I'm
incredibly passionate about our
foreshore and our proms
um you know many a time
um I see people along our shore enjoying
their Beach huts and I know that there
are many other residents that also want
Beach huts and there's a long waiting
list so you know I'm very acutely aware
of that issue
um
and I I believe that that best can be
solved um through your leisure and their
management at the beach huts and
everything that comes with that but more
than happy for us to take that take that
back and and look into that properly and
set up those meetings so yeah
uh councilor Garner
thank you yeah I I um had or have a
question and concerns I think along the
similar lines to councilor Whitehead
um
I'll ask them anyway because they're not
very long
um
the 1.3 mentions as you've mentioned a
number of leases with dual Leisure that
expire in two years on October 2024
would could you confirm that all the
other services that are contracted to
your leisure including the beach Huts
also end at the same time
and if they don't then when do they they
end I'm assuming I think you've said
they do so
I'd assume that my concern does regard
the options
um we seem to be there's a danger that
we're
that the your leisure contracts will be
rolled over Beyond October 2024 without
a full assessment of all alternative
providers
so please can you confirm that this
won't happen that there will be
investigating alternative providers of
order Services currently provided by
your leisure and how would this
assessment process be managed and I'm
assuming one of the answers is there
will be a meeting with Shadow cabinet
and group leaders to fully explore these
options
um before any decisions are made thank
you
whoever they may be in 2024. um
thank you leader and thank you councilor
Gardner for your question I can confirm
uh that all of them all of the
Agreements are due to expire in October
2024 so that includes uh the management
of the beach huts and the provision and
all of that
um on the the second point that you made
um I think it's important that we be
relatively quite positive about your
leisure and you know in the same way
that we wanted earlier in this cabinet
meeting to provide assurances to ramsco
football club and the disposal of that
land and that asset I see no reason why
we can't provide assurances to your
leisure who operate these facilities on
behalf of the council and for residents
have done it that we can't be able to
provide them with some assurities
um
of of them continuing to do so I'm more
than happy for us to have meetings um
about this and discuss it in a very open
and transparent way as we always do
um so I'm more than happy to take that
thank you councilor Pugh um I think
that's that's what I have under 20.1 so
it has been moved do I have a secondary
councilor Bob bayford or did you want to
speak
oh
okay far away
it's interested in Council of Garners as
we should look to Alternative providers
I don't think people will be falling
over themselves to take over Leisure
centers right at this moment in time and
I don't think your leisure are given
enough credit for the fact that they've
weathered some considerable storms it
appears better than some Leisure centers
in other parts of the country so
um you know there seems to be a an
implication that there's something
better around the corner but I think
that you know your leisure their merits
need to be looked at as well as perhaps
occasional uh things we think could be
improved
I think that's a very good point
um Leisure facility
Outsource management has struggled very
much over the pandemic and even prior to
that so I think that's a very good point
um
so I need a seconder
councilor Jill bayford do members agree
so item 10
. I'm sure that's what everyone has been
waiting for in the uh
in the visitors um Margate Winter
Gardens update and decisions counselor
Pugh
[Music]
thank you chair
we understand acutely that the Winter
Gardens has been a vital part of
margate's year-round offer
it is a valuable asset to the council
and its communities and the council
understands that it is much loved by the
local community with a great deal of
interest and passion about his future
this passion has been presented to us
through a petition and we would like to
acknowledge the four council's referral
of this petition to this meeting
we're in a fortunate position that we
have Revenue funding from central
government through the Margate Town deal
to commission experts to review the
building to inform on its future this
will allow us to provide up-to-date
information to our communities and we
will put more information online to
inform our residents of what we are
doing therefore I would like to
recommend and I've got four
recommendations one that we note that
the Winter Gardens the Margaret Winter
Gardens was handed back to the council
in the middle of August from your
leisure and has subsequently temporarily
suspended operations two to note the
petition signed by 2000 signatories were
submitted to the council requesting a
public meeting it has been recommended
that the council does not hold a public
meeting but ensures that further
information is added to the council
website with a timeline of next steps
and it is recommended through the review
of the nighttime economy that engagement
with danics communities is undertaken to
understand how they would use the Winter
Gardens I will however offer that uh
when we have further information as I
have stated in a council meeting some
months ago and something that we can
present to people to Residents in the
community that we will have a meeting
about the Winter Garden so I think it's
important to know that
recommendation number three we are asked
to agree the next steps in delivering
the Margate Town deal Winter Gardens
project including commissioning experts
to complete a costed structural survey
commission a complete set of drawings
for the site identify all legal
requirements and commission a team of
multi-disciplinary Consultants to review
the nighttime economy in Margate and the
Winter Gardens the role in that this
will include engagement with thanet's
communities to understand the audience
potential for a venue and finally
recommendation number four we give
delegated authority to the interim
director of property in consultation
with the economic development portfolio
holder and the director of regeneration
to market the Leisure opportunity at the
Margaret Winter Gardens in order to
identify potential interest from
operators and or a commercial partner
thank you
thank you Council pew
speak under 20.1 Council Yates
uh thank you lead and thank you
councilor Pugh
um
this report into Winter Gardens is
kicking the can down the road again
and is still not giving residents a
timed plan for what is going to happen
to this venue
I acknowledge it gives details into what
the feasibility study will do
however there's still no timelines
so it continues to raise more questions
than answers
so so I hope Council Pugh as a pen as
I'll be asking
seven questions
um which I think sum up a lot of the
views
that are out there and as required and
this is why the public meeting was asked
so first
um first question
you mentioned as a timeline can we have
any indication of when that will be put
on the website
question two has the three hundred
thousand pounds for the feasibility
study been received question three
when will a feasibility study
procurement
when will the procurement for the
feasibility study begin
question four
how long will we give that feasibility
study company in order to complete the
study we're talking about one month
we're talking about a year any
indication about how long that
process we expect them to take
question five will the feasibility study
be made public when it is complete
has Council ever said earlier tonight is
our job to speak up for residents in
total over 3 000 people signed the
petition asking to hear what the plan is
for the Winter Gardens we have members
of the Margate operatic Society here
tonight and I believe the public
deserves to know the detail
so I'll just continue question six
as well as the timeline questions it'd
be good to know how many operators or
owners have shown interest in the venue
questions
um seven
is it question seven or question six you
would know councilor Yates really so
[Music]
no it's fine I know what the next
question is
um will the commitment
um tonight by Council Pugh for a public
meeting
um will that be minuteed and tonight's
meet
um uh minutes
um my last question
is about um again it's about public
involvement in the Winter Gardens
um so similar to the theater Royal can I
make your recommendation
um that we ensure local groups like
Margate operatic Society our local
schools and community community groups
will be allocated a number of days or
time
um within any future operator
Arrangement any future lease arrangement
to ensure that the Margate Winter
Gardens continues to serve our local
community
thank you
um have you got all those
I haven't yet but I will I will start
and then I will refer it to our great
director of regeneration who has been
busy making a note of all your questions
counselor Yates and and she out of
anyone will know how many exact
questions you asked even if you don't
know the number yourself
um
there's a few things I'm going to come
back on and you mentioned about how many
potential operators have approached us
um about taking on the Winter Gardens
and and running the venue
um I can't give you uh the exact number
off the top of my head
um I've got members uh members of the
public
um gesturing free and to be honest it
may be more than that because Council
Yates you're very aware that you've
referred to us people that are
interested in the Winter Gardens
yourself
um that's something that you neglected
to mention in your lengthy speech during
our council meeting when you brought
this to full Council
um of course we continue to explore all
options and we'll meet and discuss with
all viable operators who want to
consider taking over the venue um
I don't really think this is the
opportunity to grandstand
um I think that's what you wanted when
you requested a public meeting at full
Council that's why as I've stated now
and I'll continue to stay it's more than
happy to hold a public meeting when
there is information that we can share
not provide you and other people with an
opportunity to put yourself on the stage
at the Winter Gardens and attract a very
large crowd I don't think that's in the
public interest of anyone and I think
we're doing an incredibly hard job not
only have the Estates team done in
securing the building and making it safe
but it'll also be some Frontage and
posters that will be going up very soon
around the Winter Gardens to talk about
the work that we're doing particularly
with the Winter Gardens and the market
Town deal so you know without much
further Ado because I'm sure you're more
interested in hearing from our director
of regeneration I refer to Louise
thank you
um
I might not take these in the order that
you asked them
um we are finalizing briefs for the
structural survey and the legal advice
so that we make sure we have that
information to hand because we know that
it uh if we have the right kind of
knowledge around the
um structure and cost of work to the
building then we're in a better position
to engage with
um commercial operators and or
commercial Partners in terms of the Town
deal funding
um I think it's due to come in September
and so the end of this month we're
expecting that funding and we've
programmed it in to deliver within this
financial year
um
so we will be starting that work
imminently I don't expect some of those
commissions like the structural survey
the the drawings of the building will
take particularly long to do as long as
they're booked in with
um the organizations that need to do
that
um Council pughes answered the question
about interest we've had quite a bit of
interest
um I think we need to be armed with all
of the relevant information to be able
to further some of those discussions and
I think there's further interest coming
in through our Estates department so
we're taking note of those people and
then we can share the information when
we go out to the market
um
the other question around the nighttime
economy strategy so this is about
because sorry because we will be looking
for a commercial partner you know the
local Authority doesn't have the funding
needed to invest um to bring the
building up to uh the standard it should
be
um we are looking for commercial
operators and partners on that basis we
want to make sure that we've got enough
evidence to show where the Winter
Gardens role is in the Margate nighttime
economy than it's East Kent and and
broader we need to make sure that we can
prove some of that audience which is
about the engagement with communities to
understand how they would use the Winter
Gardens what would they be willing to
pay how would they use it
um
Etc but it it will also help inform what
other
um entertainment venues Leisure venues
they're doing in and around Margate so
it will be a public document and one
that we can share because it's important
that others can take advantage of that
as well and there'll be things in there
that will also help with the theater
Royal and so we know that that's
important
one of the things that we will be asking
for in the brief out to the marketplace
is what is your offer commercial
organization in terms of the building
and the offering in that site as the
recommendation says we're going out this
is about Leisure it's about the Winter
Gardens continuing role in in Margate
thriving 365 so we want to make sure
that it works and is financially
sustainable so what we can't do is put
lots of prerequisites in that won't make
it possible for it to succeed but what
we do know is some of those people that
we have already spoken to are interested
in how the local community is part of
the Winter Gardens but what we need to
do is in the first instance is ask how
commercial organizations can make it
succeed and and have a you know a
sensible discussion about that and then
I guess in terms of timeline
um
probably towards the end of this week
maybe the following week we can start to
sketch something together that says
within this period of time these are the
things that we will be doing
um I don't have a length of time on the
feasibility study yet that will be more
for those or sorry the nighttime economy
study that'll be more for the
Consultants to put forward and say this
is how long we think that will take but
I would be hopeful that it would either
by be by the end of this year or early
next year
I'm just
okay through the chair
thank you uh leader
um
just to clarify there's
it's been mentioned tonight that there
will be a public meeting
is that just cliver that's not part of
the nighttime economy consultation this
is a separate public meeting is that
correct
sure if I can come in yes counselor
Yates that will be separate and it will
be completely separate from that
um I'm not going to fob it off and
include it as part of the nighttime
report consultation
um if that's what you're thinking
uh and to just to reiterate that
on the previous meeting that we had then
you know I would as soon as things are
starting to roll on it then obviously
we've got something to say but it will
be a really silent public meeting it's
no point getting everyone's expectations
up until we've actually in a position to
make any
um
firm sort of indications about what is
going to happen going forward I mean
everything is underway and it is a
rolling machine but it's no point until
we're at very very early doors of it so
um it's uh
not a conspiracy to withhold information
it's just we want to be able to tell the
public some meaningful information and
that's as simple as it is when we have
that then obviously we'll be we'll be
making those those comments
with it I mean I don't know what you
classify as a public meeting
um it's uh you know members can be
briefed in Britain briefings I mean
really the mechanism should be for
members to be briefed and then the
members to relay that to their public to
their Wards to their to their residents
um
so I don't know which form that that we
that you envisage it being in but um I
imagine that um the first stage will be
the cabinet sharing information with the
members and then it will go from there
so um the first Port of Call for any
information should always be to the
members
um because that is our duty to make sure
that members know what is going on here
so um if that's uh okay does that that
cover your your concerns
um
I don't think we understand what the
public meeting will look like
um at the end of this meeting so as one
has been offered it'd be good to
understand are you saying that it'll be
a cabinet meeting or are we saying
you'll actually be a public meeting
where yeah
I mean it will be it will be a public
meeting a public meeting it's a public
meeting it won't be a cabinet meeting it
won't be a member's briefing
um it will be a public meeting
okay so councilor Austin
thank you leader I'm afraid I I have to
disagree with the the uh idea that
having a public meeting will be silent I
don't think it'll be silent at all I
think it's indicated by the number of
people who signed the petition and the
number of people in the public Gallery
this is an issue of considerable concern
um councilor Pugh mentioned earlier on
about openness and transparency I don't
think it would do any harm to hold an
initial public meeting with those who
feel strongly about this and another one
later I know we're all pressured for
time but really I I mentioned earlier
that the the way it looked for us not to
have had a debate about our pressing
housing issues I am also concerned about
the way it looks that we're not actually
taking on board that the level of public
concern about about this matter it may
be that we don't have a huge amount to
tell people but at least we can listen
to them that would be really helpful
um with regard to infamous Nation going
via Ward councilors oh I wish if I did
not have to work full time trying to get
information to share with a residents
because I would be delighted we are we
are talking about the Margate Winter
Garden yes I know we are respectfully
remind you that actually the Margate
Winter Gardens isn't actually in your
wall it isn't but I would really like to
be kept informed for example the um
nighttime economy review I really
welcome that but councilor Garner and I
must have been asleep because we didn't
know anything about that but really
welcome it and I'd love to know how we
can contribute to that because we've got
big issues with the night time economy
in my ward
um can I just sorry the nighttime
economy review is for the Winter Garden
it's specific to the Winter Gardens it
didn't it didn't read that way I'm sorry
I've misunderstood
it would be good to have a broader one
however
um the final pointed I wanted to make
and it's the one that I make all the
time and counselor Pew and I go
backwards and forwards on this is the
the matter about not having had a
long-term business plan and having lost
external funding this is the point at
which I say when I was a senior local
Authority officer I would have been
sacked if this had happened and where
are our business plans etc etc and that
is not intended in any ways a criticism
of our existing officers we have a small
but beautifully marked regeneration team
who have to put everything out to
Consultants I really think we need to be
looking at beefing up that team so that
we have stronger work there a broader
range of skills and we can be producing
these business plans in timely fashion
and also sharing them widely with both
members and residents thank you
so Council appeal I'm not sure there's a
direct question about the Winter Gardens
but if you'd like to comment
thank you chair no there wasn't um but
I'll come back anyway thank you cancer
Austin
um
I mean look you know we talk about openc
open and transparency and everything I
mean I don't think there's been uh up
until now an administration of this
Council that has been this open and
transparent
um I think that's incredibly important
to note that's not criticism of other
administrations but I think it's a key
pillar of this cabinet of what we want
to achieve and I don't want to offend
Council organ of course
um but somebody I'm not going to say it
um I think it's incredibly important to
acknowledge that you know the Winter
Gardens is a treasured building for many
residents not just in Margate but the
wider area I do accept that I have very
fond memories of going there I'm not
going to say it was the last time was
when I was primary school age as I have
with other cabinet reports here
um but it was far more recently than
that you know I think that's really
important the point that was made about
having a silent meeting I think the I'm
not going to speak for the leader but I
think the point was is that as I
reiterated as our full council meeting
when this was brought to full Council
and if I recall there was quite a lively
debate and there was quite a good debate
then about the Winter Gardens and the
petition that councilor Yates brought
forward so I wouldn't say that members
haven't had an opportunity to debate
this and to discuss it in an open public
forum in probably the most transparent
way possible
um it's incredibly important that you
know if we hold a public meeting and I'm
saying that we will hold a public
meeting but there's no point holding a
public meeting if we don't really have
anything to share with the community I
appreciate that residents may have
questions I'm answering questions all
the time from residents
my email is publicly available my phone
number is publicly available it's
probably now making a rod of my own back
but you know I'm very very able and very
happy to respond to Residents that have
concerns as I have been doing this
entire time when they've had questions
and voice concerns about the Winter
Gardens you know as I know all councils
are so you know I don't really take the
point that you know a public meeting is
is the only opportunity that we as an
Administration or counselors can listen
to Residents because I think there's a
variety of ways of doing that you know
again we can hold the public meeting and
we will hold a public meeting but I want
to make sure that we have enough
information to share with residents not
that it's an opportunity to grandstand
because we've got local elections coming
up next May thank you
counselor.com
thank you
um
well most of it's been said
um and Council Austin took words out of
my mouth about um listening and I don't
think the meeting would have been silent
at all an example of which I think there
should be a public meeting now
so one question that might have come up
at any public meeting could be
how can we be sure that the Winter
Gardens won't be sold off to a housing
developer in the absence of any other
information people are generally worried
about this kind of thing so it's those
are the kind of questions that could be
answered at a public meeting just to
allay those fears right now
thank you
can I just come in before that
oh
sorry Chad thank you um thank you
councilor Duckworth for your question
um
look I think it's incredibly important
to note that you know uh that has been
declared in a public uh in a public
forum
um I've declared it many times that you
know the intention is not for the Winter
Gardens to be sold off or residential
um I even took part in an interview with
I believe it was Kent online
um last year or earlier this year
um it may have been the beginning of
this year I lose track but I'll try and
dig out the article uh where I
categorically stated that that would not
happen you know just from a property
perspective the site isn't suitable for
residential development I can tell you
that now and I'm saying that in a public
meeting it's not even if it was that
wouldn't be
um you know the direction of travel that
this Council would want to go down you
know the Winter Gardens is incredibly
valued building within the community you
know I don't really think that it's the
business of this Council to sell off
assets to build residential development
um you know and again it's one of those
myths that gets banded around and is put
on social media and everyone stirs up
and everything and you know and I'm I'm
happy now to dispel that you know that's
not going to happen it's as simple as
that you know
again that can be stated again in a
public meeting but I find it would be a
bit of a waste of everyone's time if we
all gathered in the Winter Gardens and
that was the one overriding question
that residents wanted to ask because the
simple response is no as cancer Saunders
said it would be a short meeting it
would be almost close to a silent
meeting which everyone seems to fixate
on it's important to make that clear and
I'm happy to make that clear but as I I
said earlier in my response to councilor
Austin you know my door is always open
I'm happy to respond to any questions
that that residents have and counselors
have as I always have
um so therefore there are opportunities
and avenues available
um for this cabinet myself and the rest
of the cabinet the council to answer
questions from residents but when the
time is right we will hold a public
meeting
councilor Bob Byford you wanted to come
in
yeah thank you chairman
um over the years as a counselor I've
sat on the stage of a number of public
meetings and I've got the scars to prove
it
um I think that there is a real risk if
we'd had a meeting at the time when
councilor Yates was calling for it that
all you'd have got is a room full of
angry people shouting at the people on
the stage and at the end of it they
might have felt a little bit better
people on the stage would have felt a
little bit worse and nobody would have
been any of the wiser and we wouldn't be
any further forward I think the the
thinking back over the years the most
constructive public meetings I've been
to is when there has been some kind of a
proper agenda where there's been some
kind of a proposition that's being put
to to the audience for the audience to
comment on and and those have been very
useful and I think that when we're in a
position to do that that's the right
time to do it there will be no point in
having a meeting where you just had sort
of people find fired up you know coming
out with all sorts of wild suggestions
or indeed conspiracy theories which we
know abound in thanet I can't see the
point
I can't resist though saying at this
particular point that I don't think it's
a great pity I mean there is a lot of
interest in the Winter Gardens at the
moment and perhaps if the local
population had paid as much interest in
the Winter Gardens over the years as
they are now no I'm serious now you know
the fact is that you know we've seen
other situations where you know there
have been people protesting outside of
public assets where you know the
protesters were bigger than any audience
that ever sat in the venue that was
being looked at you know at the end of
the day no I'm sorry that that at the
end at the end of the day I I would well
I mean I I know from people from people
I know and talk to about this that you
know the number of times that most
people I know have visited the Winter
Gardens is not very good it's a long
long time ago for a lot of people and I
think that coincides with its decline
I'm sorry
because
sorry Chad just wanted to to add for the
benefit of everyone here that you know
you know I do take on points
um do you take on board the points that
have been raised and something that I've
neglected to add until now mainly
because I've been focused on answering
questions
um is that you know as a council we're
trying to make sure the information goes
out far and wide about everything that
we do one of those things is uh the
future of the Winter Gardens and and the
long-term future and success of the
Winter Gardens and because of that
um why I have now taken part in with
other uh members of the council and
offices
um in records in some short pieces to
camera at the Winter Gardens it was a
couple of weeks ago we were organizing
this video to be put out that will be
shared on our social media channels
because you know there's other ways it's
just another example of other ways that
we're trying to make sure that we dispel
some of the myths there are about the
Winter Gardens and that as many people
within the community are assured at the
position that we've taken and what we're
trying to do here
[Music]
um
councilor Whitehead I believe you're
down to speak
thank you leader
um thank you councilor p
as I stated in the report the Winter
Gardens is an asset of considerable
cultural and financial value
which is of huge interest to the
community as a whole
my requests in relation to its future
are simple
that communication is prioritized with
all of the community and not only
stakeholders or those who are likely to
be directly involved in this process in
order to reduce confusion and distress
and that our communication as a council
is proactive as reactive responses are
always far harder in terms of clarity
and trust and that necessary works and
plans to bring this building back to the
quality of life that it should always
have had begin as soon as possible and
are as clearly communicated as possible
this is a hugely significant asset and I
know that it is one that we all cherish
it is hugely important for residents to
visibly see that understand the work
surrounding it and feel involved in all
parts of the process
that is what I hope for and I know that
we can deliver as a council
thank you
would you like to thank you Chan thank
you councilor Whitehead and I completely
agree with everything that you've said
so thank you
foreign
so before I'd just like to reiterate
again that
the
intention is to find a suitable investor
operator whatever we can do to bring
this about building back into action
there is no intention
it's certainly under this Administration
for ever to be anything considered
regarding residential so I hope that we
can just lay that ghost completely to
bed tonight and I can assure you and we
will do everything we can in this
Administration to find the right
solution and matters are being
explored and so nice and I will be the
first person to understand on
the public Gallery wherever it may be
and declare that there are certain
entities interested or how we can
provide a future
um you know I I've been there a lot
um my dear third cousin appeared at the
Winter Gardens many years ago
admittedly dressed as karma Miranda but
I do have a close affection of the
Winter Gardens and I've been there many
times in fact Heather small is wonderful
at the Winter Gardens and I've been
there to every one of her so I'd just
like to say that we all share the same
passion and we are doing everything we
can to find it but this this does need a
long term sustainable future and the
only way we're going to get that is
serious investment so we have to find
that but it won't come through the form
of residential I can absolutely
categorically state that under this
Administration there will be no
consideration for residential included
in any bids that might come in on on the
future of this of the Winter Gardens but
we will do everything we can and it is
very much up there in my top priorities
and the priorities of this cabinet
because we know it's important but it's
not just important to Margate it's
important to the whole district and I
want to keep reiterating that all of our
assets are important to this District if
this district is ever to be able to
replenish its pot of uh reserves so it
is important that we act in a very
commercial way as well but we need to
find the right solution for the Winter
Gardens and I'm sure that we can so I
just hope that everyone gets behind that
and and puts a bit of trust in that and
um
we will obviously advise everybody as
much as we can as soon as we know
so that's me sort of summing it up from
there
um and it has been
do you want to re as it's been quite a
long while since you did it do you want
to just reiterate it and then we'll uh I
will chair thank you otherwise everyone
will forget so I would like to put
forward a cabinet and recommend the
following recommendations number one
that we know the winter that the Winter
Gardens was handed back to the council
in August from your leisure and a
subsequently temporarily suspended
operations two to note that a petition
signed by over and I'll add that in
Council Yates over 2 000 signatories
were submitted to the council requesting
a public meeting it has been recommended
that the council does not hold a public
meeting but ensures that further
information is added to the council
website with a timeline of further steps
it is recommended through the review of
the nighttime economy then engagement
with thanix communities is undertaken to
understand how they would use the Winter
Gardens and I will also offer however
that when we have further information
um and something to present then we will
have a meeting a public meeting about
the Winter Gardens recommendation number
three we are asked to agree the next
steps in delivering the Margate Town
dual winter gardeners project including
commissioning experts to complete a
costage structural survey commission a
complete set of straw of drawings for
the site identify all legal requirements
commission a team of multi-disciplinary
Consultants to review the nighttime
economy in Margate in the Winter Gardens
and the mint Winter Gardens role in that
and this will include engagement with
danics communities to understand the
audience potential for a venue and
finally recommendation number four we
give delegated authority to the interim
director of property in consultation
with the economic development portfolio
holder and the director of regeneration
to market the Leisure opportunity at the
Margate Winter Gardens in order to
identify potential interests from
operators and or a commercial partner
couldn't have put it better myself
counselor Pugh do I have a seconder
councilor David Saunders do members
agree
thank you cabinet so thank you members
officers and members of the public